IT IS TIME TO PLAY
POWER POINTLESS: VIDEO EDITION.
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE YOUR
UPCOMING POWERPOINT PRESENTATION
A LITTLE JUICE, JUST ADD SOME
STOCK VIDEO. WORKS EVERY TIME.
IT'S GOT THE OTHERWORLDLY
CREEPINESS OF STOCK PHOTOGRAPHY
BUT IT MOVES, JUST LIKE A "HARRY
POTTER" NEWSPAPER.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU AN INEXPLICABLE OF STOCK
VIDEO FOR SALE ON THE
INTERNET,
AND FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU
TO GIVE ME THE NAME OF THE
PRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT? FIRST UP, LOOK AT
THIS ASSHOLE.
>> YES.
LAUREN LAPKUS.
>> C.E.OHHH YOU'RE SO CUTE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS FUN FELLA.
>> AH.
I AM GUESSING, LIKE THE FIRST
ONE, ALSO WEARS A DIAPER
FROM TIME TO TIME. DAVID
KRUMHOLTZ.
>> THE SIMPLE JOYS OF THE
LAUGHING ORGASM.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JAMES DAVIS.
>> THE LIGHTER SIDE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
>> Chris: YES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
POINTS.
KIND OF A MAD MAGAZINE REFERENCE
TOO.
LAUREN LAPKUS.
>> SO YOU WANT TO BE THE MOST
[BLEEP]ABLE MAN OF ALL TIME.
>> Chris: POINTS.
I WAS ABLE TO SCRUB BLOOD OUT OF
SHEETS.
NEXT ONE.
THESE POST-COITALS, THESE
POST-COITALS.
WHAT'S THAT?
>> LAUREN LAPKUS.
>> HOW TO BAIL ON A THREESOME.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
>> Chris: DAVE.
>> HOW TO CHEAT ON YOUR HUSBAND
INSIDE AN IKEA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE EXACT RIGHT
MOMENT TO CREEP OUT
OF THE FLURFNUUG.
>> NEXT ONE, THESE TWINSIES,
THESE TWINSIES.
JAMES.
>> HOW TO GET A BONER
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
DAVE.
>> WE ARE ONLY 26 YEARS OLD AND
WE JUST SWITCHED FROM METH TO
CIGARETTES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
LAUREN LAPKUS.
>> YOU SHOULD SEE WHERE THE
SMOKE COMES OUT OF.
>> Chris: YEAH.
POINTS. NEXT ONE.
THESE BROS.
YES, LAUREN LAPKUS.
>> HOW TO TURN WOMEN GAY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: POINTS. DAVE.
>> DANCE OFF YOUR MAN BOOBS.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
FINALLY, FINALLY A PROGRAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: AND THEN FINALLY
THESE OFFICE MATES.
>> YES, DAVE.
>> WHITE LIVES MATTER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]